[Music]
what if you found out
that you had a long lost relative
and what if that long-lost relative
was from a different planet in our
galaxy
and what if this faraway planet was home
to billions of humans just like earth
but these humans don't look
anything like us because they're from
the future
could aliens be future versions
of humans how far ahead of us
would they be how much
would they have evolved would we be able
to
understand each other and
what would meeting future humans mean
for
humanity on earth
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if aliens were future humans
in 1947 a mysterious object
crashed in the desert near roswell new
mexico
you all know this story but could it
really be
aliens the mysterious object was
officially declared to be a u.s army
air force balloon but then decades later
u.s navy commander george w hoover who
had
top secret clearance revealed that the
mysterious crash
involved time traveling humans
somehow these future humans had
developed the technology to
overcome the technological limitations
that prevent
us present day humans from making the
same type of trip
some theories suggest that these future
humans
travel back in time in order to
understand their biological past
maybe these same time travelers helped
our ancestors to make huge leaps in
scientific
and technological knowledge in a
relatively short amount of time
but if any of these theories are true
should we be prepared for another alien
human visit
sometime in the near future and
what might we expect from this close
encounter
of the third kind if aliens
i mean future humans were to come and
visit us again they would probably look
similar to how they appear in movies
like us they'd still walk on two feet
but
their heads and their eyes would be much
larger
this fits with predictions of how
present day humans will continue to
evolve
we can expect our heads to be bigger and
our
upper skull to become more rounded to
accommodate a larger brain
and as our civilization advances enough
for interplanetary travel
our eyes would get bigger so we can see
better
in dimmer environments that are further
away from the sun
future humans might also find a way to
slow the aging process
so it would be possible to make several
trips to places
thousands of light years away within one
lifetime
if we want to travel somewhere that's
sixty thousand light years away
and if our technology could do it then
it would be a sixty year flight for
anyone on board
but when they got back to earth sixty
thousand years would have passed we'd
like to think that
humans of the future would solve this
problem so
they could visit earth and come home to
tell their family and friends about
their trip
but if future humans find a way to live
for thousands of years would that lead
to a massive overpopulation on whichever
planet they inhabit
well chances are if they make it
possible to live that long
they will probably succeed in optimizing
their existence before that
their civilization would undoubtedly be
a lot more efficient than ours
the reason being is that they could be
centuries if not millennia
ahead of us in evolutionary terms
future humans would be a lot smarter and
they'd have better technology to
maximize their space
and live in densely populated worlds
without producing the same high levels
of pollution
that we do on earth in fact you could
bet
that future humans wouldn't just have
better technology
they'd be technology just like some
humans today have
implants to perceive sound or to detect
atmospheric pressure
the humans of the future would likely
have dozens of technological implants to
make their lives easier
think about everything your cell phone
does for you
now imagine you could command it with
your thoughts
and that it would only be a small chip
in your brain
a chip or implant like that might also
explain why
those who claim to have encountered
aliens have said that
the aliens spoke to them in their native
language
could future humans simply have
automatic language translators
implanted in their brains or would
humans of the future
evolve past different languages
instead using one universal language
like esperanto if you think this topic
has
more to it than just a what if then why
don't you join us on the what if disgust
podcast
we go further in depth with the
possibilities of aliens
actually being humans from the future
with dr mike masters of montana tech
university
who has written a book postulating that
aliens are actually future humans
traveling back in time to better
understand their past
by better understanding us